hello everyone and the welcome to game
number five of the 2013 World Chess
Championship match between viswanathan
anand and magnus carlsen if you've seen
my previous videos on this match you
know that the result so far has been all
four games were drawn and now Carlsen
once again has the white pieces so he
will try something different in this
round and it was you know every chess
player in the world was following this
chess championship and it's interesting
a move by move you know every move they
made and there was a you know like a
Twitter campaign and every chess player
in the world posted something on Twitter
about every move so I have some of the
tweets already for this game so hope you
will enjoy this as well not really
having the best of luck finding any
photos from round 5 I did find one this
is the one from round 5 probably
probably during the opening but it's
really funny so many photographers and
so so few photos of this match so let's
see it cousin has the white pieces and
he opens with C for the English opening
so far he tried nice to have three but
he didn't really get any results in in
those games so going for the English now
we have e6 the iron core defense d4 d5
and Knight to c3 and then goes c6 so
keeping all of his options open and you
know checking to see what Qasim will
play and here we have the first move by
cross and that really surprises everyone
Anand and everyone efore this is a the
Marshalls gambit of the Queens gambit
and all the Queens gambit declined and
it's a an extremely sharp variation here
I prepared a nice tweet for this moment
here you can see uh nigiri posted this
he says wow Carson going for the
sharpest line did he lose his mind so
it's it's the sharpest line because
after D captures on e4 which was played
in the game Knight captures on e4 comes
the Bishop to b4 check under display
Bishop to b4 and this is a
the sharp line that everyone was hoping
to see from Carlson Bush up the blocks
and now comes Queen captures on d4 and
after Bishop capture some before then
Queen captures on e4 with Czech nice to
e2 and black does have an extra pawn
here but White has the Bishop repair and
his pieces are a bit more active this
Bishop is preventing the King from
castling for now and it's very
interesting that it's impossible to grab
even the second one because then Queen
to b6 is coming and it's gonna be very
hard to play this position with black 97
93 is coming preventing black from
exchanging Queens so black will be two
points up but with a very passive
position and what would of course enjoy
playing this but after this Bishop to b4
check it seems Carlsen I didn't want to
test the islands preparation in this
very sharp line so he plays nice to see
three and here we have another quote
another tweet by Geary he says six nines
93 take my words back still the same
magnets there so now everyone sees that
Carson isn't interested in this but he
plays a normal move you know keeping
everything still open
we have c5 now comes a three and Bishop
to a5 Bishop captures on c3 also
possible after B captures simply keep on
developing but Anand prefers and not
giving up the bishop pair so early in
the game so after a three Bishop to a5
and now comes Knight to f3 Knight to f6
Bishop to e3 and Allen plays nice to see
six under once Crossin to capture the
pawn on c5 if Carson goes for a pawn
with D capers on c5 then Bishop captures
and c3b captures and now look at these
triple pawns this is a terrible position
for white black can either exchange
Queens you can keep the tension going
with Queen to a5 castling is also an
option
so not the thing you want to do with the
white pieces across some place Queen to
d3 a very nice move preventing this
knife from jumping to e4 also may be
preparing queenside castle in some
variations and keeping an eye on c3 so
the bishop eventually does capture the
Queen can also capture back
see capture Sun before night capture
Sundy for and now we have a knife to g4
on and correctly value is the position
and he wants to grab one of the bishops
too you know
so Carson will definitely lose the
bishop pair here and Carson goes for a
queen-sized cast a very bold decision
and thus captured the bishop we have
night captures F captures on III and
here if you check out this position
Anand is Anand is definitely better here
Carson's bone structure is a bit
deteriorated a bit he has three pawn
islands on a test two point Islands and
Anand still has the bishop repair so the
only thing Carson has for him in this
position is a bit more development so I
don't you definitely keep on developing
here either by castling by going Queen
to e7 here Knight captures on d4 also an
option but here are not played a move
that everyone was baffled with he played
Bishop to c7 and this allows Carlsen to
immediately go for the endgame and you
know mess up on spawn structure as well
so Carson does played he plays Knight
captures on c6 b captures and now Queen
captures on d8
Bishop captures on d8 and if you look at
this position now instead of you know
having a better cone structure and
everything you know on the board across
and skink position was a bit loose and
now Anand also has three point islands
and the only thing he really has going
for him is the bishop repair but it's
not it's not all that much if you don't
get to the bishop we're working it then
the bishop error isn't very strong if
you remember the Avengers immortal
against Garry Kasparov and here we do
have one quote by Garry Kasparov himself
he says on Twitter again cross and got
next to nothing in the opening amazed
Anand went into the endgame could could
take on d4 keep Queens on very different
game so in that position were on and
played Bishop to c7 here we're going
Bishop to the c7 and a lot of the same
game Kasparov said oh just simply not
capture on d4 keep the Queen's on the
board and you know
because Pavlov's attacking he loves
activity so this is probably what he
would have gone for but okay
this is what was played and we reach
this end game Bishop to e2 Carson wants
to go to have three with this Bishop and
maybe take advantage of this week pawn
King to e7 brush up to f3 and now Bishop
to d7 defending so Anand does have the
bishop pair but it's still a very
passive Bishop repair Knight to e4
we have Bishop to b6 and now c5 cousin
doesn't allow honor to activate his
bishops we have f5 and now he can either
move the bishop back or he can give up
the bishop pair and go for even some
more exchanges so on and evaluates this
is good for good for black f5 we have
pawn captures pawn captures night and
now Anand probably saw here Bishop
captures and they capture some b6 and
black is perfectly fine here
but after this F captures only for Anand
amidst a very a very simple idea that
slightly improves cousins game his pawn
structure and the game so instead of
recapturing immediately try to pause the
video and try to find a nice in-between
move for Carlsen so I will give it a
couple of seconds as usual so for those
of you who were able to do this
congratulations you are an excellent
endgame player and for those of you who
just won in your show it's quite you
don't seem simple but you know be sullen
so now black has to react to this he
cannot capture the bishop and allow be
captures an a7 so rook a to b8 was
played and only now bunch of captures on
e4 rook captures on b7 and now rook H 2
f1 cousin fully mobilized his his forces
and instead of having this phone from a7
come to b6 by recapturing across and
spawn caller calls and push it to b7 and
now instead of having that position were
Anand had the better pawn structure and
the better game now Carson does have
this little advantage the material is
completely equal on the board the both
players have a light square Bishop to
rooks
but now on Carson has three points and
Anand has four and you all know you know
rooks really like
those lonely pawns so rook to b5
this is a one move that was that was
very much praised on the Internet at the
time uninflated is it's a very nice move
Costin goes for rook to f4 and now g5
kicking the rogue back rook to f3 and h5
now so Carlson will definitely double
rooks on DF file rook d2 F one bishop we
ate and now push it back to sea to rock
the c5 rook to e5 was slightly better
here keeping an eye on this III pawn as
this does prevent Carlson's next move
but okay rook the c5 pinning the bishop
here
Bishop to g6 would definitely be an idea
that would exchange a lot of pieces but
Carson goes rook to f6 preventing this
and you know really increases the
activity of hit of his rook and the
islands h8 rook is still completely out
of the game so we have h4 and now II for
now better up to g6 will no longer be a
threat even if the rook moves we have a
five pink to d2 rope the b5 now
attacking the pawn b3 Bishop to h5 and
now King to c3 rook the c5 check and
came to be two now Carlson's King is
safely tucked away rook to d8 and
finally under manages to activate his h8
rook we have rook or 1/2 f2r up to d4
attacking me for pawn and now comes Rock
to h6 Bishop to d1 hoping to exchange
bishops but now crossing plays Bishop to
B 1 a very nice smooth look to b5 here
attacking the b3 pawn and here King to
c3 this is the only move that allows
Carson to play this position on we have
a king to c3 defending the pawn by
attacking aaron's rook on d4 we have c5
defending the rook and now rook to be 2
we have E 5 solidifying that rock on e4
rook to g6 now going for the g5 pawn and
we have a for crossing place rock
captors and g5
route capture some b3 with check rook
captures and now Bishop captures on b3
rook captures on e5 with check King d6
now look back to age five and if you
look at this position Carson has now won
a poem but Allen's position is very
active so this King cousins King doesn't
really have all that many squares and
this position should be honored should
be able to hold this position to a draw
rook to d1 attacking Carlson's bishop we
have E 5 now with check King moves and
now Bishop to h7 going for some Bishop
to g8 ideas and this is the critical
moment in the game here aren't played
rook to see one with check the correct
idea was actually hooked to a one simply
going after the a three-point and after
Bishop to g8 check King moves now Bishop
captures some b3 a curse true captures
an a3 that's the whole point
now the bishop is pinned and black will
simply recapture this acting King c4 and
now capturing this with the a pawn and
now the material is equal and this will
be played out to a draw but here after
Bishop to e7 rook the c1 check was
played we have King to be 2 and now rook
back to G 1 and here we also have a very
nice tweet by Nakamura he says that he's
truly baffled by each of Allens moves
from move 39 onwards but especially this
I hope to see one move that we've just
mentioned so after Luke to g1 attacking
the pawn we have Bishop to g8 check King
c6 and now rook to h6 check first
improving the position before exchanging
bishops King do seven and now comes
Bishop captures on b38 capture some b3
and now can capture some b3 so being up
two points now rook captures on g3 and
now rook captures on h4 now Carson is up
two points and this position is now
winning for white we have King to e6 we
have a four passed pawns must be pushed
King captures on e5 and now a5
king - king 36 rook to h7 King to d5 and
now a 6c for Kim to c3 rope - a - you
have to keep an eye on this
spawn pawn comes to a7 here King to see
if I was played and here cross and just
played h4 and black cannot keep an eye
on both the a pawn and D H pawn so in
this position and move 58 Vishwanathan
Anand resigned and a first victory in
this world chess championship match goes
to Magnus Carlsen
so first four games were drawn here a
very nice victory by Magnus Carlsen and
here we have after this game was played
Garry Kasparov tweeted his famous tweet
and that is why I used this quote above
the board you can see it's a code by
Siebert arash before the endgame the
gods have placed the middle game and
then Garry Kasparov after this game
tweeted that tar said before the endgame
the gods have placed the middle game
sadly for Anand in the endgame the gods
have placed Carlsen so yeah by winning
this game cross and definitely shows
that there is there is a new era in
chess as there is a World Chess
Championship challenger is able to
impose his will against a world champion
in an equal endgame so this is something
very you know very very tough to deal
with for Anand and the Garry Kasparov
was of course very happy about this as
you know Carson is his student after all
and you know Anand tried to take away
the World Chess Championship title from
Kasparov and now Kasparov student is
trying to take away the World Chess
Championship title from a half from
Vishwanathan Anand his old rival so a
very interesting game and a very
interesting set of choices you know it's
not all that we're done and missed this
rook to see one Czech idea it's not like
you will give on in the disposition and
he will miss the idea of course not but
cousins endgame was so strong that he
forces you to make the best decision
every move and if you don't do it every
move for 40 moves or 50 60 moves on you
will lose the game so yeah a very nice
game by Carson I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual I will put a couple of useful
links in the description below also
there will be a link to the press
conference after
after this game was played you know
cousin down and both will talk about
some of the moves that we've mentioned
so you're welcome to check it out it's
not a long video it's some seven minutes
video so you don't feel free to check
that out as well so I would like to
thank mr. I Mackenzie and Philip Gregory
for a contribution to my channel I think
all for watching as usual you can check
to all my previous videos here I will
make both of them games from this world
chess championship match and once again
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon so yeah I'm gonna enjoy the
festival now that's going on in my
hometown so see you soon